there's been a lot of news and a lot of
interesting stories with complicated
characters yeah why this one here's an
institution which is hostile to feminism
where many of the women in in the
institution can't even use the word and
yet these women did a relatively
remarkable feminist thing and it was
just a fascinating story so they they
were humans who were complex and
complicated and contradictory we
sometimes act I think as though having a
movie made about using a ward we gave
you in Hollywood here's your reward for
doing something Noble or whatnot but
what we're really interested in is
complicated characters who's whose
internal conflict is unusual and they
had very very unusual internal conflicts
in a way that is rare in you know a lot
of these kinds of media driven stories
and so yeah it was it was it just to be
offered that palette of human beings was
was pretty remarkable Jay is I
understand it part of how this wound up
in your good hands had to do with
Charles sharing this script with
Charlize her sharing it with you and a
certain reluctance that you both had
what was that although she had some
she'd been attached to it sort of
loosely or at least had had it in you
know in her office for a couple months
and I'd been trying to figure out how to
do it and she said it to me just as a
friend we were working on another
project and she asked me to just give
her some notes and so I wrote up a ton
of notes cuz I was really hooked on the
predicament on on what it what what it
was like a year before the Harvey
Weinstein story broke for these women to
take on this powerful man and for all
the dilemmas that led to him actually
being fired by the Murdochs it's just
just an incredibly compelling story and
I and the other thing I said there was I
think it's an opportunity to show how
nonpartisan the issues of sexual
harassment are as much as people will
come out there was so many
predispositions which
sighs you're on the right would probably
be predisposed to think we're just doing
a anti Fox you know hit job just them
just to undo Fox and the left would
probably be skeptical of of you know
being asked to go along this journey
with these Fox women these characters
and I thought that's was that's that
sounds amazing let's let's do that and
and try to get it right do be authentic
about it get people past their
predisposition certainly go past the
media presentations of how those women
and the N Fox is presented to understand
what goes on behind the scenes when they
are faced with crises but also to get
past even the woman's own the you know
the these people's own self president
you know presentations they have a thing
that they have to put forward to fit
into Roger Ailes is you know cult of
personality and I I said all that to her
and I don't know if she was thinking
this before she called me but at the end
of the call she said I'll do it if you
directed and I was I guess I was
surprised
I've known Charlize for a while but I
think we've only talked about comedies
even though I've mostly done political
films in the past few years and I guess
I maybe it was just self deprecation ism
but I just thought she always saw me as
sort of the clown table director so I
I've seen myself as someone to direct
Charlize Theron and a drama I just
didn't know I would be at the top of her
list on this particular film so it
wasn't hesitancy to I just honestly was
stunned and but I it was up for about
five seconds and then with her and this
great script I said yes right away and I
did you know we'd talk about well okay
this is gonna be hard we're gonna have
to we have a big obligation to get this
right and so those were just natural
ongoing two years long kind of
trepidations nothing I never really
hesitated about doing it and John any
trepidations from you for playing this
man who has some issues so we said no
not at all it was a fantastic character
and when I got a call from my agent out
of the blue I knew nothing about this
project
many elements were already in place
these gentlemen and J I'd worked with
before and just we're great friends it's
a wonderful man to work with Charles you
know k Oscar winner for the Big Short
who is this great storyteller who had
demonstrated how he can untangle an
extraordinarily complex story and
Charlize Nicole and Margo were already
set so before I even read the script I
said yes I was dying to do it and very
exciting
what point in the process they even
thought of me for the role I I
objectively I'm not that much like Roger
Ailes I but I think it came in handy
that I'd recently played another old fat
bald man so they knew I had it in my kit
bag yeah but no no hesitation whatsoever
and I read the script and it was even
better than I expected
can you talk about I mean he's a bit of
a corpulent kind of guy you had to go
through quite a transformation can you
talk about I mean the makeup in this
film is it's really something and how
that affected your performance when you
were able to see yourself and all of
that well I assume there are a lot of
actors in the audience tonight it's
always an incremental process I had
these incredible Confederates Colleen
Atwood who's done a lot of Tim Burton's
films she does amazing things with
bodies not just costumes but bodies we
spent lots and lots of time getting the
body exactly right and just how far we
should go I'm he he was a big ungainly
obese man and I was all for that I
gained 500 pounds that's pretty
impressive he gained all that way no it
was all fat I was all offense that's why
he's sitting it up in the back I was
very skeptical about prosthetic makeup I
just one very ironic story I had played
Churchill with nothing at all glued on
my face I did
a wig that made me look even more balls
than I am but the only prosthesis was
inside in my jowls not my nose and
simultaneously gary oldman was playing
churchill with loads of prosthetic
makeup designed by kazuhiro who became
my and that was a tremendous
oscar-winning makeup job and je gave me
confidence and he also he just said look
let's experiment with it let's see what
happens and I spent a very exciting day
in Casas extraordinary studio and I just
couldn't believe my eyes when we were
done not only the look of it but the way
it felt on my face or didn't feel at all
it just felt like me and if I would
shake my head my huge
double chin would waggle back and forth
like a turkey it was so extraordinary
realistic so you just do all those
things on the outside and it makes you
feel very different on the inside a
certain humiliation and self-loathing
kicks in one of the most fascinating
things is that roger ailes was not
necessarily seen as a complete and utter
monster was actually very well liked by
a lot of folks John what what do you
make of the guy now that you've had the
chance to sit in his skin for a bit well
I've told this story quite often I the
the most interesting and revealing piece
of work I did in preparing to play the
role it was tracking down an old friend
of mine from the 1970s who had worked as
Roger as producing partner when Roger
was attempted to be a theatre producer
in New York a fun fact Roger Ailes
produced the premiere production of hot
L Baltimore by Lanford Wilson you know a
significant piece of Pulitzer
prize-winning drama
he was also starting his media
consultancy with kab political
candidates my friend Steven Rosenfield
back in those days was working with him
12 12 hours a day on both of these
enterprises and they were very good for
and he said nobody nobody says a word
about what great company Roger
Albus was but you know his very edgy and
ironic sense of humor most revealing of
all he could be very tough on his own
political candidate clients for being
too conservative too hard asked
right-wing and had and lacking in
empathy and III we have got this forty
minute conversation with him telling me
these amazing stories about a totally
different Roger Ailes and I couldn't
wait we'd already started shooting but
you remember I couldn't wait to get to J
and Charles and tell them about these
tales it's not that I was trying to make
him more sympathetic I just wanted there
to be more to him than just a despicable
villain I mean everybody
whenever I'm when I told anyone that I
was about to play Roger Ailes or that I
have played Roger Ailes their reaction
was entirely oh how can you play that
monster well you play a monster monsters
don't think of themselves as monsters
they are all they in my my guess I'm not
a monster myself but my guess about
monsters is they hate their own
monstrous behavior they wish they didn't
feel compelled to behave that way they
were there almost in the grips of that
and that's what I tried to project at
least a little bit in these scenes I
mean I embraced the role of the villain
of the piece there's no question and the
scene we're talking about is like the mm
white-hot molten core of this film it
this is where we demonstrate what
absolutely every woman in the film is
reacting to and both Margo and I and
Charles and Jay we all we had a terrific
meeting long before we start shooting
where we talked about just what the role
of this scene and this relationship is
in telling the whole story we knew what
we we knew we had to disturb people
tremendously
there is another pivotal scene here
Charles
to ask you about and that's the one
where Kayla confronts Megan can you talk
a little bit about some of the dynamics
there between those two women yeah
that's my favorite scene because it's
that generate the great generational did
not seen second favorite scene yes this
is this great generational conflict
right that we see playing out right now
every day between a you know a
millennial who insists on zero tolerance
and and you know a gen Xer who you know
is dealing with the old way of seeing
the world and being in the world so so
we really you know in the story of as
make it are Megan the story is a woman
who's coming to terms with how
compromised her decisions have been and
allowing a progenitor coming after her
to be victimized it was it was something
that you know really felt necessary to
do and and and in a way is the sort of
heart of her journey I think of the
Megan characters journey so so yeah I
you know film history is full of people
like us leaning into character
sensitives and K'naan who were and we're
ambivalent about and i genuinely believe
Charlize delivers on megan kelly
because she's so in some ways torn about
the real underlying person and i think
that's always a sign of where you're
gonna find gold you know as artists you
know art complicates you know it's it's
a canvas not a mirror and so it's really
just about leaning into those things
that that scare us and and and are
complicated and that dynamic felt like
one of those moments where you know we
could really show exactly sort of what's
going on and in in that place in a way
that was a little bit surprising yes
charles john jay thank you so much